the fact that johnny depp's career was  actually completely sabotaged it was  like no maybe people do deserve to kind  of see this given the fact he was like  the star and then disappeared so yeah i  had that same conversation like is this  okay is this a reflection of a healthy  society yeah yeah basically yeah but  then i thought about it and i was like  well she's the one who brought this  whole story to the press she made this a  worldwide announcement and it deserves  to be  reconciled as a worldwide announcement  if that's what you came to the table  with so that's the thing that's  justified it for me but i still feel  that same  creepy feeling about just watching  people display all the intimate ins and  outs of their relationship